been a long time let's not ever be aart
this long
forever and of
course right on Q always when we come
back big news Diane Feinstein our
senator for so no don't laugh uh no she
was a great serving Senator here died
today first female uh uh mayor of San
Francisco and everyone there today
observed a minute of no
shoplifting
cuz
let me tell you when she was mayor of
San Francisco she had that city under
control when there was poop in the
street it was because John Waters was
making a
movie also a senator for 31 years in
politics for 54 years not once was she
caught on tape giving a hand job at a
musical I I think that has to
count well you
saw
you've seen Lauren bobbert she's the
Maga uh Congressman I guess she's a 36y
old grandmother uh she is from Colorado
uh family's value Republican was caught
on tape she was at Beetle Juice like
getting her tit grabbed vaping grabbing
I'm not making this up this is your
government at
work and
uh
so they threw her out of the theater and
on the way out she gave them the finger
and said do you know who I
am I see this is the difference between
Republicans and Democrats when Biden
says that he's genuinely
asking but uh okay good news and bad
news about our government there's going
to be a government shut down again do we
what what the why do we always go
through this it looks like I know I know
it's terrible for a lot of people on the
bright side the Senate approved a dress
code solving a problem they created last
week really although it's just for the
men uh Christen Cinema you're familiar
with her uh she retains the right to
dress like Kate McKinnon as weird
Barbie and
there there was a republican debate this
Ronda santis is here he was on it
apparently he woned according to the
polls but it was a
show was it not did you see this I
couldn't get through I mean they were
just talking over each other made me so
tense I had to calm down by watching a
video of Britney Spears dancing with
knives
I this thing was I I I always play the
Republican debate drinking game that's
where you take a drink every time go oh
God I need a
drink